Glanz und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus 23 Dezember
ein Tag vor Heiligabend ja nur schon in
Weihnachtsstimmung du geht so geht so
nach diesem Jahr geht so ehrlich gesagt
und irgendwie
wächst meine Sehnsucht nach nach einer
schönen Weihnachtsgeschichte ich könnte
dir eine erzählen wirklich ja ich könnte
dir erzählen deine
lieblings-weihnachtsgeschichte also
erstmal würde ich sagen fallen mir viele
ein ja aber wenn ich so es gibt eine
eine Geschichte die nenne ich jetzt mal
Weihnachtsgeschichte ist keiner aber die
kann man gut zu Weihnachten erzählen und
die habe ich das erste Mal gelesen aber
ich 18 okay da habe ich die Brüder Karam
mal so versucht zu lesen
ganz großes Buch die Eltern erinnern
sich an die Verfilmung und Maria Schell
und wenn man das Buch liest dann ist man
konfrontiert mit tausenden von Namen und
die haben im russischen auch immer noch
Kurse Formen und das ist ein ziemlicher
Kampf aber wie dem auch sei es gab ein
Kapitel im fünften Kapitel erzählt der
Atheist Ivan dem Kleriker Aljoscha
seinem Bruder eine Geschichte
und sie spielt zur Zeit zu hohen Zeite
Inquisition im Spanien im 16 Jahrhundert
und dort gibt es einen großen Inquisitor
der ist schon 90 Jahre alt und völlig
verknöchert und der hat gerade mal
wieder ein ganz großen Stil Heretiker
verbrannt
also
ja Ungläubige und so weiter die von der
Inquisition also als minderwertig
gefunden wurden und da taucht dann
dazwischen diesen ganzen Leuten im Volk
also ein Mann auf der wird sofort von
den Anwesenden merkwürdig angeguckt ja
der schafft es sofort einen Blinden zu
heilen und die Leute wissen wer das ist
ja wir würden heute sagen er ist wieder
da ja also Jesus auch ja mitten in der
inquisitionszeit ein Comeback sozusagen
für die katholische Kirche das Größte
was ihr passieren kann also wir haben
der Beweis für die auch verstehen
und das nicht wirklich gegeben hat und
das wäre ja großartig da könnt ihr jetzt
sowas wie Papst werden aber es passiert
nicht sondern er wird natürlich
festgenommen er wird übrigens aus dem
gleichen Grund quasi festgenommen wir in
der Bibel festgenommen wird nämlich
wegen Ruhestörung dafür die Ordnung
nervt er nervt ja er und dann am Abend
geht dann der große Inquisitor zu ihm in
die Zelle und fragt eben auch ein
bisschen wiedergekommen ja und dann
erklärt er ihm mal also dass das Letzte
was die Welt jetzt noch gebrauchen
könnte wäre das Jesus zurückkommt wie
die Kirche hätte so eine Ordnung
errichtet über so viele Jahrhunderte mit
all den Schwierigkeiten und so weiter
und jetzt käme er und wird das alles
durcheinander bringen
und dann wird Jesus am Ende zum Tode
verurteilt ja weil das ist sozusagen als
oberhiretiker aber Jesus verzeiht ihm
und gibt ihm einen Kuss
und das ist diese
diese merkwürdige Geschichte natürlich
frei ja genau aber liebe ja aber das
Interessante an dieser Geschichte ist ja
dass sie so realistisch ist ja total
also wenn es im 16 Jahrhundert gespielt
hätte wäre das sicher so heute wäre
Jesus Medienphänomen wenn er
zurückkommen würde würde ihn jede
Talkshow eingeladen aber damals als als
als die katholische Kirche noch eine
Syndikat war dass die gesamte Kultur des
Abendlandes beherrschte wäre das der
größtmögliche Unfall gewesen wenn Jesus
zurückgekehrt wäre weil es hätte sie ja
auch absolut daran erinnert was sie
eigentlich sein soll eine Religion der
Liebe und nicht eine Religion des Todes
und eine Religion die dem Leben
zugewandt ist ja ne eben nicht eine
Religion des Todes und auch die die ich
ich habe als Kind habe ich sehr schnell
wenn du so Kat aufwächst wie ich es
getan habe ja dann kriegst du zum
Beispiel ganz schnell mit und welche
unglaubliche Rolle Sexualität in der
Religion spielt ne ja und ich habe
irgendwann mal einen sehr klugen Satz
dazu gelesen von jemandem der sagte das
ist logisch dass ich praktisch alle
Religionen um die Sexualität ganz
besonders kümmern der diese ist eine
richtige Fixierung auf dieses Thema
warum wer die Sexualität wer den Körper
eines Menschen kontrolliert der
kontrolliert eigentlich den ganzen
Menschen
ich finde das ist aber schon der zweite
Schritt bestimmt weil der erste Schritt
war eigentlich was anderes man muss ja
überlegen dass die Religionen in einer
Zeit entstanden waren in der ist keine
weltliche Rechtsprechung gab
und indem das auch keine
festgeschriebene Organisationsform von
Staaten oder sowas gab ja sondern die
meisten Religionen also die großen Welt
Religionen die monotheistischen sind in
der elevante entstanden also eigentlich
eine in derselben Region haben die alle
ihren Ursprung und für Hirten
Nomadenvölker so und was war der Sinn
von Religion Ordnung zu schaffen ja was
darfst du was darfst du nicht ja im
Grunde genommen ging es um eine Art
sozialkodex so haben alle Religionen mal
angefangen nein jetzt könnte man lange
reden wie ist das im fernen Osten
gewesen aber die abendländischen
Religion die monotheistischen Religion
da ging es darum dass man gewisse Regeln
des Zusammenlebens machte und jetzt die
Frage warum ist Sex so wichtig die
jüdische Religion war auch immer eine
Seuchen Moral und das spielte eine ganz
große Rolle das gilt spielt auch für den
Islam eine große Rolle also wenn jeder
mit jedem kann und darf und macht dann
gibt es zwei große Probleme
das eine Problem ist Übertragung
sexuelle Übertragung von
Infektionskrankheiten und Seuchen immer
schon ein großes Problem der Menschheit
schon lange vor Aids und das zweite
Problem also man denkt ja mal hier an
Hepatitis B zum Beispiel was darüber
übertragen wird und was eine Geister der
Menschheit ist das Menschheit gibt und
das zweite ist die erbrechtsfrage wenn
man nicht weiß von dem die Kinder sind
stellt sich die Frage wer ab die Chance
Eifersucht und wem gehört was um ihm
gehört was nicht und unserem Ende immer
um die Kohle ja und deswegen war Sex
ohne wichtige Sache man musste wissen
von wem die Kinder sind oder das alles
musste in einer geregelten Ordnung
funktioniert und und der größte
Konfliktstoff ja der sich normal unter
normalen Völkern einstellte waren
sexuelle umgekehrtheit
auch Eifersucht und Rache und alles was
damit einhergeht und deswegen war es
wichtig dass ein Ordnungsrahmen dafür
davon lebt bis heute die ganze
Regenbogenpresse von sexuellen
umgekehrtheiten ne absolut soll man
sagen das stimmt so Maria ganz
grundsätzlich Religion ne du wirst mal
ich meine es ist der 23 Dezember und ich
finde ein schöner Anlass um mal ein
bisschen ketzerischer zu werden ja
Frage
genügt es nicht zu sehen dass ein Garten
zum Beispiel dass der einfach schön ist
ohne dass man dann auch noch glaubt dass
irgendwelche Feen darin wohnen
oh ja
nein
ja
ja genau das ist doch das ist doch der
Punkt also die warum warum haben wir so
ein so ein Bedürfnis oder irgendwann die
Idee entwickelt wir müssten jetzt alles
so spirituell irgendwie aufladen und
dann am Ende über Spiritualität auch
wirklich zu Religion zu die Idee haben
wir gar nicht entwickelt die sitzt sehr
sehr tief für Menschen drin glaubst du
ich habe dir mal erzählt ich hatte ja
mit Jane goodle ne dieses Jahr eine
Sendung genau die berühmte
Forscherin und die sagt ja dass es bei
Schimpansen wenn auch wahrscheinlich nur
bei männlichen schimpern sind
Spiritualität gibt
von überzeugt sie sagt dass sich die
männlichen Schimpansen in regelmäßigen
Abständen und das haben sie überall die
50 Jahre die sie beobachtet hat gemacht
zu einem ganz bestimmten See im Wald
gehen dort gibt es eine bizarre
Felsformation und sie sagt das ist für
als Menschen würden mir sofort sagen na
das ist wie so ein Haien oder so
tunischer Ort und so empfinden die
Schimpansen das auch und
Australien sowas sowas wahrscheinlich ja
und dann dann dann treten die rhythmisch
im Wasser
rhythmischem Wasser und Trommeln sich an
die Brust was ihr untypisch für
Schimpansen ist ne was kennt man so von
Gorillas aber wir machen ein Geräusche
oder
bis sie fertig sind dann sind dieses
quasi in so einem transzustand und an
diesen die verzückt ja auf den Felsen ja
und starren in die den Nachthimmel
das machen die nachts ja das machen die
nachts
gespielt
also was wir unter romantische Liebe
verstehen Mann und Frau und ähm die
Herzen schlagen über Jahre gemeinsam das
gibt's nicht bei champanzen aber
Spiritualität gibt es also wenn das
stimmt dann ist die Spiritualität älter
als die Liebe die geschlechtliche Liebe
was anderes ist natürlich die Liebe der
Mütter zu ihren Kindern und so ne die
gibt's ja überall unter Säugetieren aber
Spiritualität scheint sehr tief in uns
drin zu stecken und jetzt mache ich mein
anderes fast auf ich habe mich meine
Zeit lang für zwei Leute interessiert
einen Herrn Piercing und einen Herrn
human
amerikanische Neurobiologen
die versucht haben zu beweisen dass wir
eine Art religiöses Zentrum im Gehirn
haben
so und jetzt könnte man ja gesetz den
Fall dieser Beweis wäre überzeugend und
zu dem Ergebnis kommen und sagen naja
gut dann liegt das einfach daran da ist
irgend so ein paar Drähte quasi Defekt
ne die schmoren dann bei bestimmten
Gefühlszuständen und deswegen sind wir
religiös aber die behaupten beide dass
das ganz anders ist sondern dass Gott
uns diese Region quasi geschenkt hat
eingebaut hat ja als Werkseinstellung
und das Buch von jungen heißt weil Gott
wohnt go away also warum ist der liebe
Gott nicht verlässt ja weil er sich in
uns verankert hat in unserem Gehirn
okay und das glaubst du nö ich finde die
ich finde diese diese Erklärung also
Neurowissenschaften Neurowissenschaften
auch vom Stande der 80er 90er Jahre ja
wirklich also das ist das mit den
Mitteln kann man solche Sachen nicht
beweisen religiöses Zentrum ist ein
gigantischer Begriff außerdem wenn es
ein Gott gibt dann hat er es sicherlich
nicht nötig und so ein kleines Teil im
Gehirn wird zu implementieren damit wir
nicht aufhören an ihn zu denken also das
macht den lieben Gott sowieso ja zu
einem merkwürdigen einem Informatiker
oder zu einem Hirnforscher oder ein
Techniker oder so absolut also das ist
ein kleiner Leute ja Leute die sowas
glauben die so argumentieren die glauben
ja auch dass die Frau aus der Rippe
eines großartigen Mannes gemacht worden
ist ja und das ist ja auch tendenziell
eher unwahrscheinlich
sagst du so in deinem Jugendlichen
sehr unwahrscheinlich zumal die Bibel
sicher der selber nicht so ganz einig
ist ne weil du beim ersten Mal werden
die am Anfang der Priesterschrift wird
der Mensch geschaffen oder wird gar
nicht gesagt wie und wo und da sind auf
einmal Mann und Frau da ja und dann wird
nachher noch eine Geschichte
nachgereicht mit diesem schnittwerk und
das ist tatsächlich ist der Grund dass
es sich ja bei um zwei verschiedene
Geschichten handelt die aus zwei
verschiedenen Kulturen kommen und die
auch 250 Jahre unterschiedliche
auseinander liegen ja ja genau
du kennst du du kennst doch Richard
dockings ne absolut der der dieses
großartige Buch der Gottes waren zum
Beispiel ja finde ich nicht ganz so
großartig und zwar für mich ich bin
überhaupt kein Fan wirklich nicht total
also nicht total nein ich mag Leute die
du bist vielleicht erklären warum ja
also die diese Idee sozusagen so gegen
den Strom zu schwimmen ja prinzipiell
mal die Frage aufzuwerfen
kann man auch als Atheist ein guter
Mensch sein ja kann man glücklich sein
kann man moralisch sein kann man nett
kann man freundlich sein und ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher selbstverständlich kann
man dass ich treffe in meinem Leben
immer wieder unheimlich nette Atheisten
und du erinnerst dich doch ins hatte
glaube ich mal war das Channel vor ich
glaube ja in in England so eine
zweiteilige Serie ich glaube die hieß
die Wurzeln Wurzel allen Übels genau
darum das Religion die Wurzel allen
Übels ist ja der der Titel dieser Serie
dieser Dokumentation ist sehr reißerisch
aber es gibt eine berühmte Anzeige dazu
kennst du die nee es ist ihre gute
Geschichte ähm also es gibt es gibt äh
diese Anzeige die wird für diese Serie
und die wird geschaltet in diversen
Tageszeitungen in England und so weiter
und was du siehst ist folgendes du
siehst die Skyline von Manhattan und
ganz deutlich auch zu sehen die die
berühmten Twin Towers ja die die das
world Center und darunter der Text
einfach nur die Zeile stellen Sie sich
an der Welt ohne Religion vor
und jeder versteht sofort das gemeint
ist klar dass die Twin Towers noch
stehen würden so und die Frage ist ja
eine Welt ohne Religion keine 11
September keine Selbstmordattentäter
keine Anschläge in der Londoner U-Bahn
keine Kreuzzüge keine Hexenverfolgung
kein ewiger Krieg zwischen Israelis und
Palästinensern aber jede verfolgende
Menge anderer Mord also wie viele keine
Kritiken als Christ zu Mörder und so
weiter keinen
atheistisch waren ja ja also die größten
Schrecken des 20 Jahrhunderts haben
Ungläubige angerichtet weniger gut als
Argument ne nein also oder sowas anders
für Frauen die sich Frauen zwei
haarsträh zu zeigen dass du alles was
auch ohne Religion und gibt es auch in
anderen Kulturen aber ich will immer
verteidigen begründet
ja eigentlich würde ich würde so
umdrehen und und würde sagen die
Religionen unsere monotheistischen
Religionen die ja allesamt Religionen
der Liebe sind
haben mit Sicherheit die Welt weder
liebevoller friedvoller unterm Strich
gemacht das heißt sie haben also im
Hinblick auf ihren moralischen Kern
diesbezüglich versagt also soweit würde
ich gehen vielleicht nicht überall durch
vielleicht nicht wohnen insgesamt mehr
Unheil in der Welt angerichtet ist als
sonst angerichtet worden wäre das ist
spekulativ da bin ich nicht ganz so
sicher da wäre ich bei dir also ich
meine wenn du dir anschaust ich sag mal
zumindest in in unserer Welt sage ich
jetzt mal ist ja Religion tendenziell
eher auf dem Rückzug ja und ich ich
erinnere mich wie Papst Benedikt ja
schon schon vor vielen vielen Jahren
darüber sehr laut darüber nachgedacht
dass das Katholiken irgendwann so eine
so eine Minderheit sein werden dass das
klang so wie die die Zeugen Jehovas
Reloaded ja das wird dann irgendwann so
eine Minderheit sein die die dann
wirklich den Kern sozusagen dieses
Christentums und und der der Lehre Jesu
lebt aber eben nicht mehr als als große
Kirche ja aber was ich nicht hier bei
Druckens ist warum schreibt man solche
Bücher also für mich ist das ein ein
Mullah des Atheismus
bin ich nicht an Gott glaube dann ist
doch das irrsinnigste was ich irgendwie
machen kann davon zu überzeugen dass es
ihn nicht gibt
also ich lasse mich von niemanden durch
irgendein Gottes Beweis dazu bringen zu
glauben dass es Gott gibt aber jemand
der jetzt das Gegenteil versucht ja und
versucht das etwas von dem man denkt
dass es nicht da ist ja dieses nicht als
nichts zu beweisen da fragt man sich
doch auch immer und das ist ja bei
dockings ist das er macht das seit
Jahrzehnten ja ja kämpfte
Modelle
unglückliche Kindheit gehabt irgendwie
in den fängenden von Kleriker ich habe
keine Ahnung aber ich würde niemals
versuchen irgendwie jemand den Glauben
auszutreiben
ich versuche nicht von Straftaten
abzuhalten oder seine Frau zu schlagen
oder so dass ich ja schon aber ich meine
am Ende ist doch nicht die entscheidende
Frage ob der eine ein bisschen mehr
spirituelle ist und der andere ein
bisschen weniger richtig ich finde diese
ideologische zwei Stellung die einen
sind die guten also die die an Gott
glauben und die anderen die Ungläubigen
sind die schlechten und von rumgedreht
genau
und die die glauben sind die schlechten
richtig der wiederhole ich doch diese
gleiche Ethik ja die nur schwarz und
weiß du machst das was die andere Seite
eigentlich macht und was du der anderen
Seite
Vorlage ich finde aber trotzdem also die
die Idee zu sagen einfach so ganz
ketzerisch und dann damit letzten Endes
ja auch die die Freiheit des Denkens und
das wiederum müsste die doch gefallen
die Freiheit des Denkens zu feiern und
wirklich zu zelebrieren zusammen was auf
ich erlaube mir jetzt mal diesen
Gedanken ich erlaube mir darüber
nachzudenken was wäre die Welt für ein
Ort ja wenn wenn ähm Religion keine
Rolle spielen würde oder umgedreht ist
Religion wirklich etwas was uns zu
besseren Menschen machte das müsste ja
z.B dazu führen dass in Gefängnissen
eigentlich vorzugsweise hatte ist sie
sitzen aber nach meiner Kenntnis ist das
nicht so und so wirklich gar nicht ja
also die größte Befürchtung wäre dass
wenn Religionen verschwinden Ideologien
an deren Stelle treten und das ist so
ein bisschen die Geschichte des 20
Jahrhunderts 20 Jahrhunderts jahrhundert
ist die Zeit in der der Glauben am
stärksten eingebrochen ist und
gleichzeitig Ideologien entstanden sind
wie der Stalinismus Ideologien wie der
der Nazi-Faschismus
und man sich eben fragt ich meine das
was diese dieser atheistischen Religion
die ist ja im Grunde genommen sind
angerichtet haben war ja noch schlimmer
deswegen finde ich ist so eine Gleichung
sehr sehr sehr kompliziert und ich kann
für mich selber immer nur sagen ich habe
ja viele Diskussionen gehabt ich hatte
auch mal im österreichischen Fernsehen
mit Klerikern eine Diskussion ja zum
Thema ging es auch um die Rolle der
Kirche und um den Wahrheit Anspruch und
ich habe gesagt die die Kirche ist für
den Bereich der Erkenntnis Theorie nicht
mehr notwendig ja also wir brauchen
nicht den lieben Gott um zu erklären
warum es die Welt gibt und so weiter das
wissen wir zwar nicht werden wir auch
nie wissen aber mit einer Gottes
Hypothese kommen wir da jetzt auch in
den Ansprüchen die wir heute an Wahrheit
und Erkenntnis haben eben auch nicht
mehr viel weiter
in der Ethik bin ich mir meiner Sache
die ich sicher also ich würde ja mal
grundsätzlich sagen alles was in
irgendeiner Form ethische
Verbindlichkeiten erzeugt die
menschenfreundlich sind die zweite
Bedingung ist natürlich wichtig ist ja
wünschenswert und wenn die Kirche jetzt
komplett aus der Welt verschwinden würde
würde dann ganz viel Gutes an ihre
Stelle treten oder einfach nicht ja
das sehe ich ein gewisser Hinsicht als
eine Befürchtung an ja also ich hätte
auch noch ein zweites Argument sag mal
ich werde gleich dein erstes ehrlich
gesagt bestätigen
ja also
ich selber komme ja nun aus einem
Elternhaus in dem wir schon ganz früher
als Kind erklärt wurde es gibt keinen
Gott und so weiter aber
wenn wir Reisen gemacht haben Kirchen
besichtigt
und
ich weiß dass ich das wahnsinnig gerne
gemacht habe ich war so gerne in Kirchen
wir sind ja nicht regelmäßig in die
Kirche gegangen außer wegen des schönen
Gefühls zu Weihnachten und da hat mein
Vater der Atheist alle Kirchenlieder
lautestens mitgeschmettert die ihr alle
auswendig konnte Religion to go sage ich
mal naja das Interessante ist die
ästhetische Faszination der Religionen
die war auch für meine Eltern sicher
irgendwo da und die ist bei mir sehr
stark also
weihrauchgeruch in der Luft habe wenn
ich in diese diese gotischen
kathedrahmen gehe ja wenn man sich dann
so klein und grünlich fühlt aber gerne
kleinen grünlich fühlt wenn man das
Gefühl hat so dass man nicht derjenige
ist der alles entscheiden muss und alles
in der Hand hat sondern sich so ein
bisschen so ähnlich wie das ja auch bei
Natur Erlebnis ist wo wir darüber
gesprochen genau dieses lustvolle sich
klein fühlen ja das ist ja etwas
klein für sich so ein bisschen fallen
fallen lassen in etwas größeres so würde
ich es mal ausdrücken und natürlich wie
gesagt die ganze Zeit Christ welche
Kunst und die ganze Sinnlichkeit die da
drin ist und ich halte es damit George
santajana das sowieso völlig
unterschätzter Philosoph bei uns Spanier
der später in USA gelebt hat mit der aus
dem sehr sehr katholischen ungefähr
hat seine Hauptwerke anfangen bis 20
Jahrhunderts war dann später in Harvard
Professor aber damals noch nicht was es
heute ist und dieser George stand da
Jana weil aus diesem katholischen Milieu
kam ja der hat diesen den Katholizismus
geliebt oder überhaupt nicht an Gott
geglaubt also er war wirklich strenger
Atheist
aber er fand das so schön ja und und er
sagte das darf niemals aus der Welt
verschwinden und deswegen muss es auch
Leute geben die an Gott glauben weil
sonst verschwindet das irgendwann an der
Welt und Leute und deswegen hat er auch
nie versucht jemand zu überzeugen nicht
an Gott zu glauben weil er einfach nicht
wollte dass das Weg geht das ist ja die
Position von Gregor Gysi ne eigentlich
ist das auch so ich habe noch nie
überleben Gott geredet wir haben
aber Gregor Gysi ja der der der
erzkommunist ja sozusagen der sagt ja
also eine Welt ohne Religion und ohne
Kirche will ich mir nicht vorstellen das
wäre furchtbar na dann kann man mal
sehen was interessant ja ich also zur
zur Unterstützung sozusagen deine These
Richard das ist es ist schon interessant
also wenn was was ich in in diesen sehr
engen alten Tälern in meine Mutter zum
Beispiel groß geworden ist das war eine
sehr enge Welt buchstäblich und auch im
übertragenen Sinn und irgendwie auch
hermetisch abgeredet und ich erinnere
mich an eine Geschichte als als damals
so die die ersten Migranten
Nordafrikaner als die so übers
Mittelmeer kamen und dann tauchten die
plötzlich in Italien auf man nannte die
so verächtigt die wukumbra ja weil sie
immer gefragt haben möchtest du was
kaufen es gab keine große Unterstützung
vom Staat und und die die liefen dann
rum über Strände und haben versucht
irgendwelchen Tanz zu verkaufen und so
weiter und denkt entdeckten dann
irgendwann auch diese abgelegenen
Bergregionen und merken auch da kann man
gutes Geld verdienen
und ich weiß noch meine Mutter fand das
fand das der war das alles unheimlich ja
die die ist nicht groß in der Welt
herumgekommen der genügte das auch und
der war das alles so ein bisschen
unheimlich sprach dann noch die Sprache
nicht und so weiter und hat die Leute
dann immer sehr skeptisch beobachtet
wenn die vor der Tür stand und
klingelten das hat sie auch genervt und
das hat sie auch gesagt aber wenn da
jemand stand irgendein junger Mann
erkennbar hungrig oder vielleicht sogar
frieren wie auch immer
dann hat diese selbe Mutter im Zweifel
gesagt du pass auf ich will nichts von
dir kaufen und Nerven nicht rum aber
komm erstmal rein und ist eine warme
Suppe so und das war sozusagen dieser
eigentlich dieser religiöse Imperativ
glaube ich in ihr der ihr gesagt hat
tuppers auf das kannst du nicht machen
da ist jetzt einer der hat erkennbar Not
und die muss ich jetzt helfen
umgekehrt habe ich das zum Beispiel bei
Muslimen wann immer ich dort war
speziell in Ostafrika häufig erlebt
diese Gastfreundschaft dieses das letzte
weggeben was du hast für jemanden der
jetzt zu Besuch kommt ich erinnere mich
an eine Familie in
Äthiopien die die an der Grenze dazu
Somalia unvorstellbar trocken da die aus
afrikanischer Graben hoch ja du kennst
das auch so die heißeste Gegend der Welt
und das war eine Familie sondern die
Wiege der Menschheit genau und und da
hatte es seit Jahren wirklich seit
Jahren nicht mehr geregnet und ich ich
sehe noch diese kleine Ziege vor mir die
diesen einen Wassertropfen erstmal in
der Wasserflasche da raus rutschte gibt
das schon mal erzählt dann gierig
aufleckte ja weil sie dieses bisschen
Wasser brauchte und dieser Staub der
irgendwann nach Jahren ohne Regen so
fein wird dass er in jede Pore in jede
Ritze deiner Kamera reingeht und da in
diesem nichts in dieser
lebensfeindlichen Welt bei 40 45 50 Grad
Außentemperatur mittags um 12 lebte
diese Familie erkennbar gezeichnet davon
die haben einmal am Tag ein bisschen
Ziegenmilch gegessen und abends gab es
mit Glück noch mal ein bisschen Brot
oder so vom Nachbar das war's so
unvorstellbar lebten dein Sohn in so
einem Verschlag einfach nur aus aus aus
Zweigen Sträuchern irgendwie
zusammengebaut und das einzige Bett das
ist darin gab für diese Familie mit
sieben Kindern war so eine ganz harte
unvorstellbare harte Holz Pritsche aber
nicht mit irgendwie flachen schönen
Brettern sondern einfach auch so Zweigen
zusammengesteckt du also wenn du dich
darauf gelegt hast dann dann warst du am
nächsten Tag das war voll wie Gerede
all diese Leute also die Eltern und die
sieben Kinder waren sofort bereit für
mich um für mich diese Holzbrücke zu
räumen wegzugehen rauszugehen draußen zu
schlafen da kommen wir uns Skorpione
oder alles mögliche damit ich als Gast
sozusagen dort das Gute unter
Anführungszeichen Bett benutzen kann und
so habe ich das ganz ganz häufig erlebt
und ich habe mich immer in der
Gesellschaft ja je ärmer eine
Gesellschaft ist umso mehr ist sie auf
Gastfreundschaft und Nächstenliebe
angewiesen angewiesen genau und ich habe
mich aber immer unter wirklich auch sehr
gläubigen Muslimen dass das hast Du
Investoren dazu z.B auch wenn du wenn du
ein Bethlehem nachts durch die Gassen
gehst er ist das ist dunkel da das ist
so es ist da hat man kein richtig gutes
Gefühl ich hatte das aber immer weil ich
immer wusste da sind Leute allein deren
Religion sagt den Pass auf dem krümmst
du jetzt bitte kein Haar und ich war
erkennbar als als du maturi unterwegs
mit mit einer Kamera und vielleicht auch
mit einer kurzen Hose also kurz zwei
Kilometer gegen den Wind sehen wer da
gerade kommt eigentlich ein ein Opfer
Angst hatte ich immer nur in
amerikanischen Vorstädten wo wo Menschen
auf Droge sind wo du nicht weißt was
macht er als nächstes völlig irrational
und wo du auch weißt mit Religion egal
welcher Religion haben die nichts am Hut
da geht's einfach ums nackte Überleben
das geht bei den anderen
du am Anfang den Aufschlag gemacht hast
im Sinne von dalkings ja ob die Welt
nicht ein besserer Ort wäre oder genau
ja aber ich will nur sagen also insofern
hast du recht also ohne Religion glaube
ich diese moralische Dimension von
Religion hätten wir
die Welt an ungemütlichere auch ich habe
Aufklärung sagen in der philosophischen
Tradition würde man ja sagen na ja gut
also früher gab es Religion ja und jetzt
haben wir Geld zu einem besseren Ort
dadurch gemacht dass wir Normen haben ja
nicht religiöse Normen also so ein
sozialkodex des Umgangs wird einander
mit anderen Worten das tut man und das
tut man nicht ungeachtet der Gottesfrage
wir haben eine Rechtsprechung entwickelt
wir brauchen keine religiösen Gesetze
mehr wir haben zivile Gesetze ja völlig
verästelt die durchdringen alle
Lebensbereiche
und deswegen gab es ja immer diesen
aufklärungsgedanken haben wir nicht
Religion einfach sinnvoll ersetzt ja
genau und das Merkwürdige ist dass das
so so abhängig ist von Stimmungen oder
von Zeiten ob man das Gefühl hat dass
das geglückt ist oder nicht geglückt ist
also wenn wir jetzt sagen so 80er 90er
Jahre in Deutschland das ist so für
viele Leute nur weil das so eine ruhige
Friedenszeit wo sie die Weltgeschichte
man das Gefühl hat entwickelt sich
eindeutig immer besser in die richtige
Richtung da hätte man so gesagt wofür
brauchen wir eigentlich nur Religion
aber wenn dann Krisenzeiten kommen ja
und man das Gefühl als richtig stabil
ist die Gesellschaft nicht und die
Menschen sind unsicher in ihren Werten
und so weiter dann kommt fast immer und
überall wieder eine starke Renaissance
der Religion was man unbedingt die
Religion hat dann doch irgendwie
Verbindlichkeit die so eine
Zivilreligion ja genau ich hat also das
ist die spannende Frage also für dieses
Projekt der Aufklärung Religion zu
ersetzen durch vernünftige Regeln des
Umgangs das hat ja zu drei Viertel
könnte man sagen funktioniert aber ich
glaube dieses letzte Viertel ist so eine
Bastion die damit nie wirklich erreicht
wird ja und wenn du dir das mal
anschaust wie weit das mittlerweile z.B
in Amerika wieder geht es jetzt unsere
Abteilung Christen ja evangelikale
Christen wie radikal wie kreationistisch
ja wie wie wie unvorstellbar
weiß ich nicht rückwärtsgewand das alles
ist was macht am Angst wusstest du das
es gibt doch diesen großartigen Song von
John Lennon ne imagine ja wo wo er ja
sozusagen genau wie diese
genau genau
keine Religion es gab Zeiten und die
vermute es gibt immer noch in denen in
dieser großartige Song von John Lennon
in Amerika von bestimmten Ladestationen
ohne diese Zeile gespielt wurde okay so
weit geht das das ist doch irre und das
ist doch das Gegenteil sozusagen eines
alles lustvollen Christentums das ist
einfach nur Verbot Verbot Verbot Verbot
und dieser die Vorstellung jetzt mal
sozusagen
existenzialistisch nur die Vorstellung
dass würde ich die Firma Fragen Richard
was war sozusagen am Anfang also glaubst
du das ist da irgendein
allmächtiges ein allwissendes Wesen gibt
das sozusagen irgendwann mal die ganze
Sache mit mit dir und mir und das Leben
angefangen hat ins Rollen gebracht
ist das ja eine Frage die mich nicht
interessiert das hängt damit zusammen in
dem Bereich der sinnlosen Fragen ja also
Fragen von jemand egal was man darüber
denkt dass man es doch nicht weiß ja mit
jeder Antwort die man sich gibt auch
nicht einen Millimeter vorwärts kommt
also ist es ja klar also Kanter das in
seinen berühmten Antinomien ja also den
Gegensatzpaaren unauflösbaren Gegensatz
waren gesagt man kann sich nicht
vorstellen dass die Erde endlich ist das
kann sich also nicht vorstellen oder die
Zeit könnt ihr auch dazu im Universum
von ihm die Zeit dass die Zeit endlich
ist können wir uns nicht vorstellen das
ist für uns undenkbar für unser Gehirn
aber dass die Zeit unendlich ist können
wir uns auch nicht vorstellen weil wir
uns Unendlichkeit gar nicht vorstellen
können das alles mal einen Anfang hatte
das ist ja sinnvoll aber andererseits
wenn alles mal einen Anfang gehabt hat
muss es einen Anfang vor dem Anfang
gegeben haben das heißt also immer wenn
unser Geist versucht sich in diese Frage
reinzurufen ja dann besteht sein Denken
nur noch aus Widersprüchen
und deswegen würde ich sagen auch in
tausend Jahren werden wir das nicht
wissen und es ist schon es gibt schon so
viele andere schwierige Fragen wo
versucht man klein bisschen vorwärts zu
kommen
auf dem Niveau von Woody Allen gesagt
hat also mich interessieren zwei Fragen
ja das die erste Frage ist gibt es ein
Leben nach dem Tod und die zweite Frage
ist werden sie dort in der Lage sein
einen 100 $ scheint zu wechseln
ja ich fand immer die die Frage total
spannend jetzt mal so ein bisschen
theologisch betrachtet Allwissenheit und
Allmächtigkeit ja also wenn Gott
sozusagen dieses allwissende und dieses
allmächtige gewesen ist ne dann wenn du
mal anfängst darüber nachzudenken bitte
klar das geht gar nicht allein da ist
schon ein Widerspruch drin ja also wenn
Gott allwissend ist ja dann weiß er ja
sozusagen schon im voraus was er jetzt
mit seiner Allmacht gleich anstellen
wird
welche Psychologie an weil Gott wenn er
jetzt pass auf wenn er sie sich jetzt
besser überlegt sich okay jetzt mache
ich mit einer Allmacht folgendes greift
jetzt ein in irgendwas in den Lauf der
Dinge so wenn er sich jetzt kurz vor
diesem Eingriff oder währenddessen die
Sache anders überlegt und sagt nicht was
auf so macht das doch eigentlich gar
keinen Sinn ich mache es jetzt anders
dann ist er an dem Punkt nicht mehr
allmächtig ja weil das hätte ja vorher
sehen müssen so alles vorhersehen müssen
Jesus irgendwie ob das eine gute Idee
ist ja jetzt sein Sohn oft auf die Welt
zu schicken und den jetzt sterben zu
lassen und so weiter und
der will das Judentum reformieren was
kommt aber raus eine neue Religion das
Christentum das war ja gar nicht so
gedacht also da läuft ja auch noch
unglaublich viel schief ja ja ja und das
hat alles mit Allmächtigkeit nichts zu
tun und deswegen würde ich mal sagen die
Vorstellung von Gott als einem Wesen der
ausgestattet ist mit einer quasi
menschlichen Psyche oder über Psyche das
ist schon eine ziemliche Glaubens
Zumutung aber wenn ich jetzt eine reine
ist der Auffassung vertrete wenn ich
also sei ihnen als eine Art spiritueller
Kraft sehr oder ich mache mal einen
anderen Ansatzpunkt ja es geht ja um die
Fragen wo wo können Menschen durch
denken seines Philosophen oder jeder
andere auch weiterkommen und nicht
weiterkommen da muss man ja sagen wir
verfügen über Wirbeltier Gehirne so
diese Wirbeltier Gehirne haben sich in
der schönen Gegend von der du da gerade
sprach sie haben Ostafrikanischen Graben
am Rift Valley wahrscheinlich vielleicht
auch noch einen anderen Orten parallel
entwickelt so in Savannenlandschaften
wie mit leichtem Baum Bewuchs der immer
weniger wurde
und unser ganzes Denken ist angepasst an
Savannenlandschaften so und was heißt
Wahrheit Wahrheit heißt zu wissen wo das
Wasserloch ist ja Wahrheit heißt wo du
sicher schlafen kannst sich sichere
Plätze zu finden das Verhalten der
Raubtiere richtig einzuschätzen und
alles anspruchsvollste das Verhalten der
anderen Horden Mitglieder ja damit ich
da schon alle sind ja sehr brutal da
nicht jemand irgendwie abmurxt und dass
du an das Weibchen reinkommst und nicht
der andere und so und in diesem Abrieb
Prozess ne oder Kindererziehung und
Umgang mit mit anderen und so so ist
unser Gehirn entstanden also sie haben
ihn total soziales gehört sozial nicht
im Sinne von nett das auch aber auch das
andere sondern im Sinne von Austausch
mit anderen wir wollen dazu gehören ne
wir brauchten immer nur relative
Wahrheiten ja und funktionale Wahrheiten
aber wir brauchten keine absoluten
Wahrheiten und deswegen hat es nie ein
Selektionsdruck auf das menschliche
Gehirn gibt solche großen Fragen woher
kommt das Universum ja oder das Böse in
der Welt und so weiter dafür ist unser
Gehirn nicht gemacht das können wir
nicht mit unserem Gehirn das ist genauso
wie Schlangen ja wahrscheinlich keine
Infinitesimalrechnung beherrschen ja
dafür können sie wärmefelder wahrnehmen
viel besser als Menschen und dafür
schaut man seitenliniensystem oder Haie
neben Elektromagnetismus war und da wird
über diese ganzen Fähigkeiten nicht
verfügen haben wir ja immer nur ein
winzigen Ausschnitt aus der Realität von
dir wie immer glauben ist wäre die
Realität nein es ist Wirbeltier Gehirn
Realität Primaten Realität und mit
dieser Primaten Realität werden wir nie
irgendeine große Aussage über die Dinge
machen die aber transzendent sind das
heißt über unser Bewusstseins und seine
Möglichkeiten hinausgehen
also ich denke gerade darüber nach ich
hatte über dieses Argument ich
und mir kommen da so ganz leichte
Zweifel also nicht jetzt du hast völlig
recht wir können die großen ultimativen
Fragen nicht beantworten ja die
wahrscheinlich werden wir es auch nicht
können das ist glaube ich auch aber die
Frage ob wir nicht sozusagen eine Art
religiöses Talent im Laufe der Zeit
entwickelt haben die würde ich immer mit
Ja beantworten wenn Du Dir mal gerade
weil du so schön die Wege der Menschheit
beschreibst ja wo das alles begann in
diesen weiten Savannenlandschaften aus
Afrikas ich meine du warst dort öfter ja
ich kenne das auch wenn du das gleiche
wenn du irgendwo im Indischen Ozean auf
einer kleinen Insel bist das gleiche
wenn du irgendwo in Grünland in in
dieser Eiswüste Nacht stehst und das
gleiche wenn du an einem sehr
lichtarmen Punkt irgendwo in den Alpen
stehst und dann schaust du nachts einmal
nach oben was du dann siehst genau das
ist so atemberaubend so überwältigend
schön ja und ich kann nicht vorstellen
dass das mit Menschen nichts gemacht hat
die das gesehen haben dass man aber
natürlich hat das was gemacht aber das
das Interessante ist doch dass man unter
dem grandiosen Sternenhimmel ja merkt
dass man eigentlich auch nur
Sternenstaub ist ja dass man merkt dass
ich bin wieder wie bei der Kirche dieses
lustvolle sich klein und grünlich fühlen
dieses sich geborgen fühlen in etwas was
größer ist und in dem Moment mache
wunderbar geborgen ja wunderbar sehr
großartige Zeile finde ich ja und in dem
Moment machen wir die Erfahrung dass wir
nichts wissen und ausnahmsweise mal
finden wir die gut
meistens ist es ein ziemlich mulmiges
blödes Gefühl wenn man das Gefühl hat
irgendwie man hat nichts im Griff genau
aber das ist der Moment wo man so
loslässt und denkt wie schön dass das
mich im Griff hat und ich das nicht im
Griff habe also diese sich wieder
geborgen fühlen wie man im Grunde
genommen sich vielleicht mal im Bauch
seine Mutter gefühlt hat oder als
Kleinkind ja und dieses aufgehoben sein
in etwas Großem das macht was mit
Menschen also jedenfalls für die die in
Empfänglichkeit dafür haben kann ja
nicht jeder eine Sensibilität dafür aber
wenn man die hat und deswegen ist ja für
dich naheliegend das Spiritualität
entstanden ist und dass man dieses
spirituelle Potenzial nutzbar gemacht
hat für Religionen um das Zusammenleben
der Menschen zu regeln dafür waren
Religionen ursprünglich da das können
wir uns heute in unseren Staaten wofür
sie dafür nicht mehr notwendig ist nicht
mehr vorstellen aber das ist der Grund
warum es Religion gibt immer
abschließend Richard was wäre die Welt
für ein Ort ohne Religion hätten wir
dann trotzdem eine Moral eine Religion
bleibt ja über der Kapitalismus bleibt
das ist sozusagen die zentrale Bewegungs
Religion die wir haben und die
liebesreligion also früher war das ja so
dass die geschlechtliche Liebe in den
allermeisten Kulturen in der realen
Praxis eine relativ geringe Rolle spielt
übrigens in Deutschland noch Anfang des
20 Jahrhunderts weil irgendwann
Wirtschaftsgemeinschaften da also die
bespielte immer eine sehr untergeordnete
Rolle und das war Glück wenn man den
anderen auch liebte ja der für einen
ausgesucht wurde aber Pass war ja auch
in unserer Kultur Erfahrung muss eine
Rolle gespielt haben sonst wäre das mit
dem Bevölkerungswachstum ja nicht so
gelaufen wie es gelaufen ist Paarung und
Liebe sind ja bekanntermaßen nicht exakt
dasselbe ja Sie können was sehr schön
ist Überschneidungen haben müssen aber
nicht aber das Interessante ist dass
dieser liebesbezug der war über die 2000
Jahre Christentum der Bezug zwischen
Gott und dir
der gott liebt dich bedingungslos
solange du ihn bedingungslos zurück
glaubst werden ja gibst und einen
glaubst das ist sozusagen der Deal und
das ist das was die Menschen heute
Liebesbeziehung suchen ja du bist mein
ein und alles ja ich will bedingungslos
geliebt werden ich will mit allem was
ich tue und so weiter von dir aufgehoben
werden verstanden werden ich will dass
du stets bei mir bist ja wieder Gott der
einen nie verlässt ja in Gedanken bei
dem anderen ist unendlich verlässlich
und so weiter sind ja alles göttliche
Eigenschaften die wir heute versuchen
ihn Liebesbeziehungen wieder zu finden
und deswegen sage ich immer das eine ist
sozusagen die materielle Religion ja
dieses mehr was uns ablenkt über den
Sinn des Lebens ernsthaft nachzudenken
weil wir ihn sozusagen immer mit
materiellem auf aufstauen und das andere
ist diese enorme Bedeutung die alles um
Liebesbeziehungen herum heute hat
und das sind die die beiden Dinge die in
einem übrig geblieben sind und die sich
quasi aus dem religiösen Kontext gelöst
haben
und wenn es keine Religion mehr gäbe
würde sich das wahrscheinlich beides
weiter radikalisiert das heißt wir
würden also ein immer mehr Kult aus der
Liebe machen und immer unglücklicher
werden ja weil je höher die Ansprüche
umso schwieriger die Einlösung ja und
auf der anderen Seite würden wir immer
mehr materielle
sinnbefriedigung suchen das ist so meine
Prozess aber das findet ihr auch gerade
statt
also beide Prozesse sind längst im
Grunde haben wir noch lange nicht das
Ende der Fahnenstange erreicht aber wir
haben trotzdem immer noch keine Antwort
auf die weiß gibt die Frage sozusagen
wäre oder anders sind religiöse Menschen
quasi bessere Menschen weil sie eine
bessere Moral haben es gibt zum Schluss
sicher es gibt eine Geschichte nein sind
sie nicht ja
ich habe Geschichte für Dich pass auf
eine Geschichte
Montreal irgendwann im Oktober 1969
kennst du die Geschichte nein die
Polizei Montreal tritt in einen Streik
um 11 Uhr 20 ist die erste Bank
ausgeraubt
um 12 Uhr mittags haben die meisten
Geschäfte im Stadtzentrum geschlossen
weil es zu Plünderungen kommt ja dann
zünden irgendwann später Taxifahrer den
die zentrale einer eines
Limousinenservice ist an weil sie von
denen sowieso schon lange genervt sind
weil die nämlich die Gäste zum Flughafen
abspenstig machen ja also am Ende dieses
Tages sind ich glaube fünf oder sechs
Banken ausgeraubt sind an die 100
Geschäfte geplündert sind ein Dutzend
Brände gelegt Tonnen von
schaufensterglas zerbrochen und Schaden
von 34 Millionen Dollar entstanden so
und am Abend dann ruft dann die
Stadtverwaltung die Armee zu Hilfe und
sagte jetzt so geht's hier nicht weiter
hier ist Anarchie ausgebrochen
um meine Frage rund um diese Geschichte
war immer also ist das jetzt der Beleg
dafür sozusagen was passiert wenn eine
Horde Ungläubiger ohne Polizei allein
gelassen wird ja oder aber ist das alles
passiert obwohl in Montreal
wahrscheinlich 1969 noch ziemlich viele
Menschen ziemlich gläubige Menschen
waren das heißt
zynisch jetzt mal formuliert brauchen
wir nicht eher die Polizei als den
lieben Gott
vielleicht realistisch formuliert
brauchen wir die Polizei für was anderes
als sie leben ja aber es ist so eine
unfassbar gute Geschichte weil sie genau
diese Frage die ich als gehört auch für
mich zu den zu den großen Rätseln ja
meines Lebens weil die die Antwort auf
diese Geschichte zu finden was ist da
sozusagen passiert sind wir dann am Ende
also ist das sozusagen die Konsequenz
aus einer zunehmenden Gottlosigkeit
religionslosigkeit für die mal sagen wer
so gläubige Menschen machen doch sowas
nicht aber so sicher bin ich wieder
nicht ja gläubige Menschen machen halt
anders
wie wir alle wissen ja also die Antwort
auf die Frage auf die Frage die
grundsätzliche Frage gestellt hast
obwohl religiöse Menschen bessere
irgendwie ob es mehr Moral in der Welt
gibt wenn es mehr Religion gibt weißt du
vielleicht so
dieses Gift besteht auch die Gefahr dass
ich einfach nur die doppelmorale
aber ich würde sagen unter den
vorbildlichsten Menschen die ich in
meinem Leben getroffen habe wo ich sagen
würde das sind gute Menschen ja also
völlig gut ist keiner ja wäre ein Idiot
muss man ja wirklich sagen also völlig
mit sich im Reinen sind nur die dummen
oder die Einfältigen ja aber man kann
trotzdem
ja trotzdem gibt es natürlich eine große
große Unterschiede zwischen dem was man
wie man Charaktere einschätzt und
Menschen und da würde ich sagen dass du
die fünf sechs sehr vorbildlich Menschen
in meinem Leben da waren zwei religiöse
drunter und vier nicht religiöser und
deswegen würde ich sagen an der Frage
liegt wahrscheinlich am Ende nicht also
die Frage ob man ein guter Mensch ist
oder nicht entscheidet sich vermutlich
nicht am Glauben
ja so viel das Wort zum Heiligen Abend
Richard
ich danke dir soviel zum Heiligen Abend
und wie George santajana gesagt hat
selbst wenn man nicht gläubig ist ja
bietet die Religion so viel ästhetische
Faszination dass wir darauf nicht
verzichten sollten und schon gar nicht
einmalig ja
dich danke dir schöne Weihnachten
wünsche ich dir wünsche ich dir auch das
nächste Woche ja Tschüss tschüss
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und Pots
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]